o is for oh look its thingy yeah that's
a chapter but here's a thing right I've
done many wonderful projects in my life
most people ask me about is actually
what it's like to be famous that's what
people I mean I don't feel famous other
so far with these you know icons here
but but in Sainsbury's I'm famous people
ask me about yeah about about what it's
like so I've written a whole chapter
about what it's like to be a B Lister
yeah they do catchphrases yes but often
sometimes the wrong ones people come up
to me a lot are you bothered are you
bothered I'm absolutely fine dear
because you're actually mistaken me for
Kathryn Tech she gets people coming up
to her going no but yeah but yeah do you
do you get mistaken for the Colin Firth
do you yeah who has me by an Oscar in at
least 10 inches right a lot of decorum
but yeah sign up for a gym once and and
the woman got on the phone she said I'm
just gonna sort out your membership when
you went yeah Colin Firth
you were telling me backstage that you
who did your first one of those was at a
comic-con oh I did a comic-con recent I
did I did my first signing convention
because I've just spent a year and
Doctor Who as a companion and so lots of
people said please come into a
convention so it's alright I'll I'll do
a convention and the great thing about
these conventions is people dress up as
characters that you've played and so or
just dress up as different sci-fi
characters and different film characters
and yet so there was a lady next to me
whose job was to sort of hand me
photographs to sign and stick the name
of the person on a post-it note so I
could sign and what-have-you and one guy
came over for an autograph and the woman
next to me who worked for the convention
said wonderful you've come as Lou knows
she meant Lou from Lou and Andy you know
the character David played and he went
now heaven
it was very embarrassing and so I went
no he hasn't
use comers who have you come as he goes
having comes it
you